so let's say I'm a screenwriter and I
email you and I say I need my script
fixed ASAP they and we agreed to work
together what are the first things
you're looking at you know I'm kind of
simultaneously looking on both a macro
and a micro level so I as I'm going
ultimately ultimately the story is of
ultimate of the utmost importance but
I'm also as I'm reading on the page
noting things so I mark things up as I
go so I may question things or I may
already have suggestions that have to do
with sometimes minor kind of things or I
can think of a better phrasing or you
know your action description isn't clear
enough especially those first 10 pages
where which are super important if I'm
getting I'm having a really hard time
slogging through those that's a really
bad sign so I might even spend a fairly
even more time trying to point that out
to help you so I'm looking at the micro
level but I'm also ultimately kind of
sitting back and looking at the macro
level how does the story work and and I
often don't know they answer to that
till I get to the very end but I'm kind
of doing two things at once and then at
what point do you send them notes and do
they have to make changes for you to
review or it's up to them whether they
want to make those changes so I what I
do is I meet with the writer either
person or via Skype and I have their
script marked up but I don't do written
notes I don't do a written report unless
you want to pay for that separately
which I don't recommend I don't think
that's a very efficient use of your
money
I mean I'll happily do it if you want to
pay me by the hour to sit and type up a
report I don't think that's a very time
efficient use of your money I think it's
much more efficient if we have so with
each of my consultations it includes 60
to 90 minutes where we talk either in
person or via Skype so I go through on
the page you know pointing out things
but also talking story I also find it
it's also it's not just that it's time
inefficient that for me to type up a
report is that the
to do that it's not a two-way thing so
it's more efficient for me to be able to
start to ask you questions and try to
find out what you were something's not
working try to figure out what it was
you you were trying to do versus being
doing some sort of detached coverage
report that's just not a very useful
tool for the writer you want as a writer
you want to know how can I make this
better so the way to make it better is
for us to talk about it let's just talk
about oh well if that's what you're
trying to do oh I totally did not get
that that was the characters flaw you
need to let's look at you know this is
very first scene and see if you can
adjust its that's the flaw they should
be saying this in the first scene so
we're gonna look at you know specifics
so I'm really kind of script doctoring
and trying to help you know I'm not just
giving you a a passive report that tells
you thumbs up or thumbs down that's it's
not very useful - who cares if I think
it's thumbs up or thumbs down you want
an eye my job is to make your script as
good as it can possibly be
so I like to have that two-way
conversation so we can talk about oh
that's what you're trying to do if
you're trying to I did not get that at
all if you're trying to do that you need
to bring it up in moments like this
let's you know I want to hear that the
characters flaws that they're jealous
they should be saying that in this
moment or they should try it doing this
so there's a two-way conversation that
happens there and are most people
receptive to when you want to make
changes or that you can suggest them I
would say 97 percent at the time right
nineteen ninety-seven percent of the
time they are and they're and and and
and that's why I generally love my job
right is that you know people pay me to
tell them what works and doesn't work in
their script and they say oh my god
thank you that's such a good suggestion
and they love it and they go with it and
then there's the three percent who I
don't know if they think I'm a run a
studio or something I'm some sort of
gate like not you know they there are
occasionally unhappy that I you know
that and it's you know this isn't a
productive thing you're not trying to
convince me you know why you're trying
to convince me your script doesn't work
when I'm telling you it doesn't work
right I'm trying to help you help you so
that you can make it work so
occasionally you fight some who's
resistant I was funny because that just
prompts something in my mind about I was
watching an interview with Errol Morris
it was an older interview and he said
most people actually don't see
themselves as they are and actually
other people are better gauges at who
they are you know that that cliche you
know I know you better than you know
yourself I've always hated that that
expression but he said that that's
actually kind of true especially in
retelling of his things do you think
that's true with writers that they don't
you mean as far as their ability or you
know I'm actually surprised that they
kind of for the most part in the reason
why 97% of them are receptive is that
deep down they do know that and that's
why most of them go well is that they're
not generally shocked at what I'm gonna
say
they might be disappointed they might
have expected it hoped that they tried
this thing and that it's you know it
worked and it didn't but they're not
shocked they're kind of like yeah I kind
of suspected it and so I'm just there
you know and they're trying and that's
part of the point some of the things
you're gonna try work and you'll be and
I'll tell you that and you'll be
pleasantly surprised and then other ones
aren't gonna work and it's gonna confirm
what you may be suspected but that's the
point of getting the draft done and on
paper and out of your head so that
someone you know I'll have a
professional read it so you can find out
what works and what doesn't work and
something zeal surprise yourself and do
better than you thought and some things
not as well so for the most part people
actually aren't so surprised you know
it's it's I think those are the three
percent are the ones who have are ones
who do have a different disconnect in
their head about what it what it is and
how it's working 97% of people don't
they kind of they hope I love every
single word but when I point out
something like yeah I kind of knew that
wasn't working and so it was you know it
resonates with them do you think writers
are very self-aware or they're just
they've been critiqued so much what
they're writing through school or
classes that they've taken whatever that
they just kind of know yeah I realize
I'm not doing active voice here I'm
doing Pat you know well I don't know
what
you think you know it berries at their
level it varies it how often they've
been critiqued it varies at the kind of
crew chiefs
I see all different levels I you know
where people are quite self-aware and
and are used to criticism and they're
not going to be defensive and they know
the things and they'll say it right I
went up we are at a point you know that
out a weakness they're like yeah I'm not
great at doing action sequences and then
there are others who are our self is
we're a self-aware it really depends
you